so imagine you're a successful public
figure at the age of 55 you hit a severe
midlife crisis so severe that you
suddenly decide to leave your wife and
four kids for another woman then you get
so carried away with your new mistress
that you text her pictures of your
genitals and then those pictures wind up
in the hands of a tabloid whoa
nightmare what happens next do the media
attack you as a pathetic old creep maybe
even a harasser do they meet to you or
dude journalists instead rally to your
defense well that all depends on how
rich you are luckily for him Jeff Bezos
is very rich the richest man in the
world in fact and when you're as rich as
Jeff Bezos is there is no such thing as
bad press coverage there was only
slobbering Bob Woodward sucked up first
Woodward is the most famous journalist
in America he once took down a president
with the unsparing toughness of his
reporting according to Axios here's what
Bob Woodward wrote to Jeff Bezos after
Bezos as crotch shots became public whoa
Jeff proud of you for stepping forward
in such a difficult situation very gutsy
and definitely right this period reminds
me of 1972 to 1974 perhaps Watergate
redux so many assaults on constitutional
government common sense and privacy
let's hope we all get it right
aggressive but careful and fair Cheers
and best Bob Woodward so that's the new
Woodward standard if you criticize Jeff
Bezos you're like Richard Nixon during
Watergate an assaulter of constitutional
government you're on American in fact
max boot agrees with that boot is
another of bezos's employees at the
Washington Post and of course a florid
toady boot wrote a column defending
bezos's nude selfies the headline was
Jeff Bezos stands his ground he stands
his ground like Joshua Chamberlain the
Battle of Little Round Top may our
grandchildren Revere his memory and
speak his name but for pure anxiousness
no one went further than New York Times
technology columnist Kara Swisher
Swisher has been sucking up to
billionaires since before the guys run
over or even born
if flattering the powerful was an
Olympic event Kara Swisher would be Mark
Spitz
according to Swisher
Jesus's behavior since he left his wife
and kids for his mistress has been quote
admirable a quote heroic moment from
quote the most important tech
visionaries and Steve Jobs it goes on
like this pornographically for an entire
column at one point this is the best
Swisher frets that Jeff Bezos says
privacy has been violated by the
National Inquirer which by the way is
true but tellingly she didn't spend a
lot of time worrying about whether
America's privacy has been violated by
Jeff Bezos and that seemed like a
worthwhile question to ask